hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to try die repeat a game
where you get success by standing upon
the corpses of your fallen friends and I
said that sounds like a game just for me
so I'm gonna give it a go
actually I'm pretty sure that's what it
is you are evil labs the biggest
corporation on the planet we do test to
improve the life of all living beings
recently we received an opportunity to
perform an experiment with our prisoners
the kuber's however they must fail in
our primary test only then we will have
the permission to do whatever we want
okay wait i completely misunderstand
what you're talking about here oh oh
look at the diversity that you have in
this program of yours I'm sure this is
gonna go wonderfully for them and
they're not gonna die in horrible
horrible ways am i playing now is that
me that me oh it me Oh dad me I'm so
adorable oh I love the pixelated style
oh that's cute man I want to play Slimer
again number one okay be afraid we don't
bite you're lying lol at least will you
be useful to subject number two in for
us well how did that kill me I'm oh well
alright then how do they kill me was it
just too much of a fall we got ninja man
coming up on the back end okay we made
it what those spikes those are spikes
Hey oh jeez so this is what the games
all about you can only progress by dying
horribly which is whoa is what I'm the
best at so as long as I'm able to die
continuously I'm gonna be able to
complete this game coolness you've made
it alright now the real fun starts oh
I thought that was the end of the level
okay Oh what is this is it booze to make
me forget my present tiny enough you
already know what to do do i ah it was
poison oh oh oh that's a sacrifice Wow I
can push around their corpses do ah miss
me
whoa the red means dead oh I should have
at least gotten that corpse a little
farther in oh I must up there all right
come on oh geez time that you died I
would be rich whoa hey pretty princess
how are you doing it aren't you a tall
drink of water I think those compliments
are for two different people but I'm
bastard well there goes the pretty
princess nice and dead yeah this time
we're gonna get it [ __ ] [ __ ] now
these tubes withstand so many of you I
don't know I'm pretty terrible at
everything so you better send more well
at some point I'll just be able to walk
through all this yay checkpoint Wow
okay well dead now that's good oh good
another one oh how am I supposed to be
able to Oh No
which is the party oh never mind
buddy did Oh nurse you can help
resurrect these poor souls oh I don't
wanna oh man if I go for that poison
bottle I'll have to die anyway because
oh come on
alright you silly [ __ ] you come over
here
I can't go for that we don't have enough
we need more bodies this is a bad
implication
just do it okay goodbye no that's not
gonna cut it
yeah oh I'm not gonna be able to get
back up I might have just boned myself I
guess I could have died up here and that
would have oh that would have been much
smarter I was a big old dumb oh I had
unnecessary casualties oh don't trust
mark apply over anything I'm never gonna
do it I'm never gonna do anything right
forever and ever as long as I ever lived
okay this time I'm not gonna be a fool
and be betrayed by the fog of war okay
we run out of poison then I'm not gonna
be able to do anything around this
bigger coffin well stop talking about my
coffin this guy's are gonna go the
distance this is back to the original
guy I think they're just getting
resurrected again we made it we made it
I thought that was gonna smash Stefan
office all right another one of these
line up the corpses here you again how
this is possible
how this is possible in I wasn't even
paying attention what are you are you
wearing you weren't a thong on your face
you thong face McNichol oh you dick he's
a survivor he's a survivor we got him we
got it we got a good you should return
this is the wrong oh oh oh what if I do
Roy's gonna kill me and some of them
hello okay now we have a situation is
the Illuminati debate the protocol are
you in
yes now we shall take over the world
somehow don't know how well let's do it
oh hi oh hell are you okay whoa okay now
what I was expecting
[ __ ] you got a thigh oh we got to go we
got to go and you got to die oh this
ain't good
oh [ __ ]
we got to go and you got to die
buh-buh-buh yeah boink okay so we can't
jump anymore for some reason gravity
gotra voiced Oh waiter oh not me I'm not
a winner
don't don't pin any medals to my chest I
am a suck yeah that's more like it
Oh get out of here you don't need
nothing I'm running out of time RNA they
didn't expect me to die this much you
could have gone through this on one go
there we go
got it nailed it won it did it I'm
awesome whoa oh that works I don't know
what exactly that portal went to that it
would kill the giant mecha Illuminati
but we did it we saved the world we
preserved freedom throughout all the
land
all hail me and my infinite clones that
don't look anything like me okay so that
was tried I repeat which is what I think
the name of the game was and that was
pretty cool I like that a lot so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought in the comments
down below
and if you got more indie games like
this let me know I want to play them I
definitely want to play these cool
little mini stories of games they're
really fun so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye